Vous y croyez,
à l’inspiration DIVINE ?
Vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les idées de dissertation
vont tomber du ciel
dans un faisceau de lumière ?
Moi,
pas trop.
Après avoir écrit DES CENTAINES
de dissertations,
je peux vous assurer :
ça ne marche pas.
Comment est-ce que j’ai trouvé
L’IDÉE
de cette vidéo ?
Eh bien,
C’EST VOUS
qui me l’avez donnée :
des élèves m’ont posé la question
dans les commentaires
et par e-mail
— et je vais leur répondre
dans cette vidéo.
Mais avant de rentrer
dans la réponse proprement dite,
on doit se demander :
DE QUELLES
IDÉES
parle-t-on ?
C’EST QUOI
LES IDÉES
en dissertation ?
Bon en fait,
c’est simple :
en dissertation,
les idées,
ce sont les éléments de réponse
au problème intellectuel,
c’est-à-dire
les éléments de réponse
à la problématique.
Dans votre plan détaillé,
les idées,
ce seront les grandes parties,
les sous-parties
s’il y en a,
et les arguments.
Donc la question
à laquelle je vais répondre,
c’est PLUS PRÉCISÉMENT :
comment trouver les idées
des parties
et des arguments
d’une dissertation ?
Là,
c’est plus facile de répondre.
Déjà,
si vous voulez améliorer
votre capacité à trouver des idées
en dissertation,
vous avez besoin d’une méthodologie
SOLIDE.
Inscrivez-vous donc
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Vous m’en direz des nouvelles,
et vous verrez qu’une fois
que vous aurez lu mon cours,
tout sera plus clair dans votre esprit,
et trouver des idées pour vos dissertations
sera plus facile.
Après,
il existe trois solutions PRÉCISES
pour trouver des idées en dissertation.
Je vais vous les donner
de la plus facile
à la plus difficile.
Regardez bien attentivement cette vidéo,
et l’inspiration ne sera PLUS
un problème pour vous
en dissertation.
La solution LA PLUS FACILE
pour trouver des idées en dissertation,
c’est de puiser
dans VOTRE RÉSERVOIR PERSONNEL
d’idées toutes prêtes.
Imaginez :
pendant l’année scolaire,
vous avez traité un sujet
sur la démocratie,
et au concours,
vous avez de la chance :
c’est un sujet de dissertation
sur la démocratie
qui tombe.
Bon eh bien,
qu’est-ce que vous faites ?
Vous n’allez pas faire
comme si vous étiez amnésique !
Non,
bien au contraire,
vous avez intérêt
à VOUS REMÉMORER
le plan détaillé
que vous avez élaboré pendant l’année
scolaire,
parce que vous allez probablement
pouvoir REPRENDRE
la plupart des idées
de ce plan détaillé,
c’est-à-dire les parties
et les arguments.
Alors vous allez me dire :
« MAIS c’est un coup de chance ! »
Bien sûr,
pour l’élève qui n’a traité
que deux trois sujets pendant l’année,
c’est un VRAI
coup de chance !
Mais pour l’élève qui a fait
CINQUANTE
plans détaillés,
sur CINQUANTE
sujets de dissertation différents,
pendant l’année
— vous pensez vraiment
que c’est un coup de chance,
si au concours,
cet élève-ci
tombe sur un sujet
qui ressemble
à un sujet qu’il a déjà traité ?
Eh bien non.
Au contraire,
c’est assez probable.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il est
TRÈS BIEN
préparé.
Si vous voulez trouver
TRÈS FACILEMENT
des idées en dissertation,
la solution,
c’est donc de traiter
UN MAXIMUM
de sujets,
et d’élaborer
UN MAXIMUM
de plans détaillés,
pour vous préparer
à l’épreuve de dissertation.
Comme ça,
vous aurez un
TRÈS LARGE
répertoire personnel
d’idées toutes prêtes
pour la dissertation
— et vous n’aurez plus
qu’à puiser dedans.
Bien sûr,
vous devez le faire intelligemment :
l’idée que vous réutililsez
doit être PERTINENTE,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle doit
répondre PRÉCISÉMENT
à la problématique de la dissertation.
Mais QUE FAIRE
si vous ne trouvez AUCUNE
idée pertinente
en repensant aux sujets
que vous avez déjà traités ?
La DEUXIÈME solution
pour trouver des idées en dissertation,
c’est de puiser
dans vos connaissances,
et de TRANSFORMER
un élément de connaissance
en une idée de dissertation.
Imaginez :
le sujet qui tombe
porte sur la démocratie,
et vous avez justement eu
un cours sur la démocratie,
ou bien vous avez justement fiché
un chapitre de manuel
sur la démocratie.
Bon eh bien,
vous allez vous en servir.
Mais le problème,
c’est que votre cours
ou votre fiche sur la démocratie,
ce n’est pas
LE MÊME FORMAT
qu’une dissertation
— c’est rare
que ce soit le même format.
Du coup,
il y a un effort
de TRANSFORMATION
de l’information
à fournir.
Vous devez TRANSFORMER
un élément de connaissance
issu de votre cours
ou de votre fiche,
en une idée de dissertation.
C’est POUR ÇA
que cette deuxième solution
est plus difficile.
Et puis ça dépend
de LA NATURE
de l’élément de connaissance
dont vous souvenez.
S’il ressemble
à une idée de dissertation,
alors la transformation sera facile.
Par exemple,
si dans votre cours,
il y a une partie
sur les différentes formes de démocratie,
eh bien vous pourrez utiliser l’idée
« il existe diverses formes
de démocratie ».
En revanche,
si l’élément de connaissance
dont vous vous souvenez
ne ressemble PAS
à une idée de dissertation,
alors là
la transformation sera plus compliquée.
Par exemple,
si votre cours analyse
les différentes formes de démocratie
une par une,
alors c’est À VOUS
d’en déduire
l’existence de l’idée pertinente
« il existe diverses formes de démocratie
».
Donc en pratique,
plus l’élément de connaissance
ressemble à une idée de dissertation,
plus la transformation sera facile.
Par exemple,
si vous vous souvenez que Rousseau
a dit dans Du contrat social
que la démocratie directe
est difficile à mettre en place,
eh bien vous pourrez
vous approprier cette idée.
Vous pourrez par exemple écrire que
« la démocratie directe
peut sembler utopique ».
Dans cet exemple,
c’est facile,
mais ça ne sera pas toujours le cas.
Vous devez estimer
l’effort de transformation nécessaire
en fonction de LA NATURE
de l’élément de connaissance
dont vous vous souvenez,
et DU DEGRÉ DE PRÉCISION
de cet élément de connaissance.
S’il est précis,
vous pourrez peut-être
en tirer une idée précise,
c’est-à-dire un argument ;
mais si l’élément de connaissance
n’est pas précis,
alors vous pourrez peut-être
en tirer une idée générale,
c’est-à-dire l’idée d’une grande partie
de la dissertation.
Et vous pouvez encore
trouver une idée GÉNÉRALE
à partir d’un élément de connaissance
PRÉCIS
— et inversement.
Mais là,
la transformation est encore plus compliquée.
Je vais donc m’arrêter là
pour cette deuxième solution
— même si moi,
c’est un sujet qui me passionne,
la manipulation des idées.
Retenez que
SI vous ne trouvez pas
une idée de dissertation toute prête,
vous pouvez TRANSFORMER
un élément de connaissance
en une idée de dissertation.
MAIS c’est parfois compliqué,
donc moi je vous conseille
de traiter UN MAXIMUM
de sujets,
de faire UN MAXIMUM
de plans détaillés,
pour vous faciliter la vie
le jour J.
Maintenant,
QUE FAIRE
si vous ne trouvez
pas assez d’idées,
voire AUCUNE IDÉE
avec les deux premières solutions ?
La TROISIÈME solution
pour trouver des idées en dissertation,
c’est…
DE PRIER.
Non,
je plaisante
— même si on n’est pas loin.
La TROISIÈME solution
pour trouver des idées en dissertation,
eh bien
c’est d’imaginer qu’on vous pose
la question de la problématique,
et que vous devez répondre.
Dans les deux premières solutions,
vous fouillez directement
dans des « stocks de réponse »
— entre guillemets —
pour voir s’il n’y en a pas une
qui peut convenir,
mais dans la troisième solution,
vous élaborez l’élément de réponse
VOUS-MÊME.
Eh oui,
c’est bien plus difficile !
Là,
je ne peux pas vous donner d’exemple,
parce que je ne suis pas sûr
de comprendre
comment l’esprit fonctionne
pour trouver une idée.
Ce que je peux vous dire,
c’est que vous avez intérêt
à essayer de SIMULER
une conversation :
imaginez-vous qu’un ami vous pose
la question de la problématique,
et essayez VRAIMENT
de lui répondre.
Vous allez voir
que vous allez trouver quelques idées
— elles ne seront pas aussi bonnes
que celles que vous auriez trouvées
avec les deux premières solutions,
MAIS…
c’est toujours mieux que rien.
En fait,
cette troisième solution,
ça consiste à faire de manière
MÉTHODIQUE
ce que font
la grande majorité des élèves,
qui ne sont PAS DU TOUT
préparés à l’épreuve de la dissertation.
Pour trouver des idées,
ils laissent leur esprit divaguer,
poursuivre des pistes au hasard,
et se perdre
— MAIS VOUS,
vous ne ferez pas ça :
vous DIRIGEREZ
votre esprit,
parce que vous imaginerez
que vous essayez de répondre
PRÉCISÉMENT
à un ami
qui vous a posé une question.
Après,
ça sera quand même
BIEN PLUS FACILE
de trouver des idées,
si vous avez traité des sujets
qui RESSEMBLENT
à celui de l’épreuve.
Donc encore une fois :
pour mettre toutes les chances
de votre côté,
faites UN MAXIMUM
de plans détaillés !
En synthèse,
les trois solutions
pour trouver des idées en dissertation,
ce sont :
de reprendre des idées
que vous avez DÉJÀ UTILISÉES
dans des plans détaillés
que vous avez élaborés
au cours de votre préparation ;
deuxième solution :
de TRANSFORMER
des éléments de connaissance
— d’où qu’ils viennent —
de les transformer
en idées de dissertation ;
et enfin,
troisième solution :
d’imaginer une conversation avec un ami
pour trouver VOUS-MÊME
les éléments de réponse.
Mais si vous voulez RÉUSSIR
vos dissertations,
vous ne ferez pas ça
— vous vous entraînerez
en traitant LE MAXIMUM
de sujets.
Enfin,
vous le ferez APRÈS
vous être inscrit
à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie.
Vous pouvez vous inscrire
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Et puis vous pouvez aussi
me donner de nouvelles idées de vidéos
dans les commentaires
— parce que pour l’instant,
les dieux ne m’ont rien donné.
Vous m’avez demandé cette vidéo,
donc j’espère vraiment
qu’elle vous sera UTILE.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour trouver des idées en dissertation.